what's up everybody on this episode
we're gonna talk about how to find
balance in your logo as a part of the
logo therapy sessions to help me with
this is gel them base all the way from
Manila Philippines the reason why I
chose this logo is because it script
logo is like down on my how are you it's
gonna seem obvious but not enough people
do this scale your logo up and down and
look at it different sizes and better
yet print it out because oftentimes when
you zoom in on the screen it could be
deceptive in terms of how legible it is
so when I look at this in a smaller size
this blob here when they squint I see a
little blob from the t-h-e okay the
first tip in trying to balance your logo
is you need to realize the letter forms
are related to each other they need to
share common curves and angles and the
best way I know how to do this is to
draw a grid in terms of the negative
space one thing here is that if I try to
look at the volume of space in between
the letters it's kind of mixed up yeah
that's another thing that I really
looked at when when I'm designing script
this is the scan gap of thing that I did
whenever I do a new logo I prep
everything up first this becomes my
guide whenever I do a strip and what I
this this trick that I do here is to use
the blend tool it's it's a shortcut
shortcut it's W tip number two in
achieving balance and a logo is to look
at letter spacing look at any three
letters and find the most difficult
pairs to Kern usually a circular form
next to a straight form or something on
an angle and once you're able to balance
those three letters that becomes the
unit in which everything else is going
to be defined by what I normally do is
to do the lowercase letters first
because it's easier to do it equates
alert letter I in script spacing is
pretty important especially and should
have the same wave as the one in here
for example so I can see that the
spacing from this side there's a little
bit smaller from this
I'm gonna just letters them this is kind
of like my base and after I finished my
basis is where I tried to stylize and
yeah I'm getting there so once I'm happy
with the layout I try to look at things
that can be improved further so for
example I see that there's a space here
maybe we can put a stroke like this so
that it further balances out I think
that this can be pretty improved but
this is one of the things that I ended
up with it's all about optical balance
and not the mathematical balance so
using a grid it's only a starting point
you need to look at and adjust things
according to your eye because
mathematically it won't line up now that
gelatin is finished let us know if you
agree with the changes he made let us
know what you would do differently to
improve this logo don't forget to
comment like and subscribe to this
channel and hit that Bell icon
[Music]